all right guys
bang bang it's lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right i'm here
with paulina she's got like a sailor
outfit on her crimp criminal
whatever this is sailor outfit yeah all
right just
steering away the ship no problem don't
forget that block fire is now a sponsor
of lunch money
if i ask you guys what they do you
probably already know but go earn 8.6
interest up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account
no brainer go to block five dot com
slash pomp
block five dot com slash pop or you can
go in the description just click the
link it's crazy
that's how it works just go click the
link and you can earn 8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account at block
fight i'm an investor i sit on the board
i'm a happy user and you'll be a happy
user too if you use the product
how fast can you say this oh pretty fast
i don't have time for facetime
somebody's facetiming me right now
don't have time for this go ahead i'm
ready okay
now i think we're just gonna look at
this the whole time all right
go ahead i'm waiting so today is
election day
the world is buzzing
is it yeah does it matter who wins it
doesn't matter who wins you should see
my twitter timeline normally i have it
curated where i don't see all the
political crap but now it's like
a lot doesn't matter it does not matter
who the president is you responsible for
you that's it
sure maybe they make a little bit easier
a little bit harder but at the end of
the day it's on you
as we're talking wall street rally
gained steam
that the dow rises more than 550 points
on election day
does this have anything to do with the
election who they think the president
might be
should i make a prediction yeah i think
i have the same prediction
yeah i don't know if people are going to
like this or not
as you all know i'm an independent so am
i
that's why we get along every election
i look at the candidates what their
policies are et cetera i don't care
about party lines i can't write anything
about that
it's all stupid but my prediction
for who is going to win in 2020
is donald trump's gonna stay in office
and i actually think it's gonna not be
nearly as close as people think
i could be wrong i understand what the
polls are saying
but i think that one of the most
eye-opening experiences
for me over the last six seven eight
months
is talking to my friends and visiting a
number of places
that are not in new york san francisco
l.a
et cetera it's real america we went to
florida we went to north carolina
we went to texas uh those places
are very very different the energy
there the way that they view the
government the way that they view
politicians
it's just very contradicting to
the content that's on twitter and things
like that to me it's interesting because
every year we talk about this every
election year we talk about how
everybody's always in a bubble and you
don't think about what
the rest of america feels and how they
view
the world and every time we talk about
echo chambers bubbles etc
and it happens every year again it
happens like i cannot believe
it's like i can actually believe it i've
spent time in georgia i've spent time in
north carolina like
it's just it's just there's a very
very different mentality yeah mentality
and just
view on the world and the thing that
shocked me
this was absolutely shocking to me i
showed point of this
uh donald trump held a rally
in butler pennsylvania the other night
uh on saturday night
on halloween night in the freezing cold
i don't know how many people were there
but there had to be
thousands if not tens of thousands of
people it literally
looked like uh uh the beatles were
coming
it looked like lil wayne was about to
have a concert i mean this was
unbelievable
and that doesn't speak whatsoever to
policies
positions uh success not success
anything
it's just that that is a big
contradiction
to what the polls are saying and so i
can't explain it
i don't know why just the feeling i get
is that that's what's going to happen
tomorrow we will talk well actually we
might not know by tomorrow right
really well another thing that's
important to remember
is we watch the documentary endless
election it's on youtube it's free if
you want to see it
it was all about george bush and al gore
and people forget that there was no
decision made
on election night that in the 2000
election
and so al gore was literally walking out
on stage to concede
and they had to stop him and be like no
there will be no concession speech
because you haven't actually lost yet
and so that took like 30 days or
something
it was very long there was uh hearings
in the supreme court
stuff so it's not that this has never
happened before but i
also my second prediction is that
both parties the republicans and the
democrats are going to
accuse the other of stealing the
election
meddling the election is rigged whatever
you can just see them lining
up for regardless of how
this plays out whether joe biden or
donald trump wins
a long night that's what's gonna happen
but i don't think it's gonna be a long
night i think it's gonna be a long
number of
weeks like this is not a tonight day and
the reason why i bring that up is
because it's becoming apparent
we have to change the way that the
system works
in order to better reflect the will of
the people
the people when they vote whether it's
the electoral college
whether it's kind of this whole idea of
mail-in ballots not mail-in ballots
all of it you can debate it's
controversial whatever but just the
general structure has to be improved
there's people who suggest force-ranked
voting and other solutions
i don't know what the right solution is
but i think that we're getting to the
point now
where this election is going to push us
over the edge and people are going to
realize
this system doesn't work the way that we
want it to work
and therefore we need to make changes so
that's it that's all i'm going to say
we will see what happens i just want
everybody to get along
i'm tired of the polarization i'm tired
of the extremism
i'm tired of the mobs i want people to
be people
yeah i plan on i talked about this last
night what i actually wish it was
that there was a candidate who was a
complete
moderate same who who could say look you
know what there's things from
the left and things from the right that
i think can be put together into a
moderate position
and they can simply say i want to
actually do the right things for people
right and that's questionable whether
some political candidates want what's
best for people or not
but i do think that there is this
feeling across the country
people who are not on twitter who
feel like their voice isn't hurt and um
i think it was matthew mcconaughey who
said it somebody asked him about his
politics and he was basically like
well um if it's like a two-lane road
and one lanes the democrats and one's
the republicans they've gone
so they've gotten so far out they're not
even on the close remotely close to the
road anymore
agreed anyway all right i just like
being an independent
you know little individual thoughts and
personal responsibility
take a little lesson all right all right
what's next i actually didn't know you
were an independent when i met you but
so am i
all right ant group do you remember ant
group this is the
it was supposed to be the biggest most
historic ipo
uh 34.5 billion but now
it has been suspended because um
so am group's controller jack ma the
executive chairman
eric jing and ceo simon who were
summoned and interviewed by regulators
in china
the shanghai stock exchange said ant
group reported significant issues
which means it may not meet the
conditions for listing
or information disclosure requirements
why are you smiling
this is a prime example of the
government why i am proud to be an
american
and to live in this great country jack
ma
last month said things that went against
the communist party's state-owned bank
narrative he basically said that the
state-owned banks
were no good in in other terms right in
over-generalization
and all of a sudden two days before
the largest ipo in history that is like
a gazillion times oversubscribed
the chinese government has said
no no no yes you are not going to go
public
you have significant issues now the
rules are changing
all of a sudden jack ma has to do
different things
and jack is now saying oh i will
implement all of your
wishes basically this is absurd
how anyone can invest in a market where
literally there's a century centrally
planned
communist party that is responsible for
that it's interesting because they're
communists
but they love doing business
no no like communists love to do
business well
that enriches the government right this
is a prime example where
uh jack ma is literally
being kneecapped by the government a
30 plus billion dollar ipo just got shut
down 48 hours before it was supposed to
go public
because the scene because the fact that
they're so vague about it he said
something at a conference
well we don't know if that's why but the
speculation is that's why okay
um but it just sucks because it's so
vague and like you don't know what's
going
on okay long live america
fast a two-year-old startup whose
technology enables quick checkouts
online
is in discussions with investors about a
new round of financing between
50 million and 200 million
the deal could value the startup as at
as much as one billion dollars according
to the information
wow i didn't even know about the startup
he told me about the startup yesterday
and he was like oh my god it's already
under a billion dollars like what the
hell is a startup
well they're two years old there is a
two and a half million dollar seed fund
then they raised i think it was 20
million
on a 200 million dollar post money right
180
pre uh 200 post uh and
now they're gonna raise at about a
billion it's only 5x from the last
valuation
which is a lot but but it's not crazy
uh and the second thing is that they are
now
uh post product right so basically
the first seed round was pre-revenue
pre-product then when they did this they
were basically
um still pre-product now they've
launched the product it seems like
they're getting a ton
of uh interest and sign-ups and things
like that
and so now they're gonna get a billion
dollar valuation it just happened real
fast because stripe is an investor
do we think this is that fast as a
possible acquisition target for
um stripe before it goes out to raise
this other money
i don't think they'd sell really right
now yeah
i don't know the team i see dom on uh on
twitter all the time and
um i think his co-founder's name is
allison if i remember correctly
uh but um yeah it's just very obvious
look they're doing everything the right
way they're building products they're
hiring
a lot of really talented people people i
know people i don't know um
and they are also really kind of
building momentum around their story and
getting people excited about it and
you know just wearing their hoodies and
doing all the things that
well it sounds it sounds dumb but what
you end up doing is you end up building
um this belief that like we are going to
be the winner
right and when people have that in their
mind it's easier to raise money to hire
people
i always get suspicious when a company
like stripe is an investor
it's kind of like i'm investing i want
to i want to see what's going on in case
i want to buy you
yeah of course oh of course there's no
doubt that the payment technology
company that stripe invested in maybe an
acquisition
target for stripe before it gets to a
billion dollar evaluation i'd be so
aggressive
okay oh i'd be a shark
well don't don't have me invest in your
company
i'm buying them all i'm buying them all
what what company
okay okay
so paypal raises crypto buying limit to
15 000
per week for eager customers okay so
let's
remind us what paypal is doing in the
crypto space paypal owns venmo
and there's obviously the paypal product
paypal has introduced
uh bitcoin and cryptocurrencies to
paypal
the product they say they're going to
introduce it to venmo in 2021
the paypal product i think right now 10
of users so they're kind of slowly
rolling it out
10 of users now have access to buy sell
or spending crypto on paypal
the response they say that they have a
waiting list that is three to four times
larger than they originally anticipated
so there's way more people that want to
use it than they thought
and then the people who are using it
keep bumping up against their
weekly limits which was ten thousand
dollars
so they're bumping it up to one or sorry
fifteen thousand to fifteen thousand
my guess is that that will continue to
grow as more and more people use it
and so this just goes to show that like
a company like paypal who did a lot of
work on should we spend time here or
should we support this what's the risk
what's the ups
they underestimated how interested
people would be and they were originally
co-signed with the libra project
which was facebook's cryptocurrency
project but then they backed out
and then i asked dan shulman who's the
ceo of paypal if he personally owned any
cryptocurrency
and said he said bitcoin and i said only
bitcoin he said
only yes that is all okay great
anything else no
burger king is doing the unthinkable
it wants you to order from mcdonald's so
basically in the uk fast food
orders and their fast food chains are
really struggling
so the uk version of burger king tweeted
we know we never thought we'd be saying
this either and it says order from
mcdonald's
we never thought we'd be asking you to
do this just like we never thought we'd
be encouraging you to order from kfc
subway domino's pizza pizza hut five
guys greg's taco
bell papa john's leon or any of the
other independent food outlets
too numerous to mention here in short
from any of our sister food chains
fast or not so fast basically they need
help
so they're asking people to go support
their local fast food chain restaurants
how are they local and it's very it's
very smart of
uh burger king but it's even better for
mcdonald's because mcdonald's like yeah
look we're so good that even
burger king's telling you to come here
but but ultimately i think look this is
this is a really kind of class act move
of just saying
look you know all what is it uh all
tides rise
or the rising tide liftoff let's list
all boats
yeah by the way i had to address a
controversy from yesterday so
wet and wild it's a makeup brand first
of all that there's a wet and wild
makeup brush oh there's a lot of wet
wild
i don't know also girl's gone wild
that's the
that's the video series i was thinking
about girls gone wild
yeah should have paid attention more
when i was a 14 year old boy at two
o'clock in the morning
it's all right okay are you done so i
got it this girl's gone well not wet and
wild
kids show okay there's an entrepreneur
in italy who's helping his business is
literally helping americans get italian
passports
his business exploded during the
pandemic
he said his name is marco permunion
he said uh his clientele is 95 american
he said that requests for his service
increased by up to 400 percent compared
to last year's the growing virus
pandemic exploded in the united states
he says i have never seen anything like
this in my decade long career
people want to become italian of course
so you all didn't know this but actually
the world started in italy
oh my god kidding i'm kidding i'm
kidding
but that means some americans who
descend from immigrants are eligible to
become italian citizens
the main requirement is that the family
member who immigrated from italy to the
united states
did not become naturalized before the
birth of the next person in the line of
descent
that means you could your great
grandfather yeah i could be
maybe i should get an italian
citizenship can i tell them the story of
your name
no oh dude it is not very important
all right what else what's next last one
um that's it are you ready for my jokes
i have two today
oh i think they'll make you laugh we
should stop calling this jokes you
should just call them
how do we know communism was doomed from
the beginning
all the red flags
okay you're trying so hard i can tell
when you're laughing internally no i'm
literally not like that it wasn't even
funny like i was just like reading a
history book
okay this is jon stewart if khan is the
opposite of pro
then isn't congress the opposite of
progress
but like that's not a joke that's more
of like a riddle oh my god
i think i'm gonna have to start bringing
the jokes i got some great jokes
all right guys that's it be safe enjoy
it
please don't leave your crazy political
comments in the comments
i'm not going to read them but i might i
will
i'll see you guys tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends